[Music]
you mentioned a words apprenticeship
what are the types of things that you
learned from Terry or picked up the
biggest thing looking back on it that I
learned from Terry was a willingness to
go forward without knowing what happens
you might know what happens next but you
don't know what happens after that but
it's okay because you're a grown-up and
you will figure it out there's lots of
metaphors for writing a novel and george
RR martin for example divides writers
into architects and gardeners and i can
be an architect if I have to but I'd
rather be a gardener
I would rather plant the seeds water
them and figure out what I'm growing as
they grow and then prune it and trim it
and you know pleat it whatever I need to
do to make something beautiful that
appears intentional but at the end of
the day you have to allow for accidents
and randomness and just what happens
when things grow so the joy of Good
Omens really I mean the best thing about
Good Omens was having Terry Pratchett as
an audience because if I could make
Terry laughs I knew you know that that
it's like hitting that Bell in you know
hitting the thing in the circus with the
hammer
if you Bing the bell at the top and
that's what I did when I could make
Terry laugh
you